[Music]
welcome to the uplift we've got a great
show for you today a great cast of
characters as well among them a pilot
flying around the world and he's trying
to set a record doing it what is that
record we'll tell you plus a librarian
who saved items left behind in books and
now those forgotten artifacts have
become something even bigger in and of
themselves also a group of baseball
players who live where and with who
we'll show you and an equestrian who
overcame the odds we're talking big odds
thanks to an unlikely horse plus the
heartwarming videos you just have to see
you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift the show
that lifts you up for at least the next
30 minutes you and me both I'm Tony
decopo we've got a great show for you
today I made a really great show we're
going to begin by introducing you to
Lissa bochner she overcame impossible
odds to become one of the nation's best
and most inspirational equestrians and
her horse became her eyesight here's
David begno with the story
have you ever seen someone on the back
of a 1200 pound horse jump a fence well
watch again
because Lissa bochner is doing it blind
I do not see this fence at all until
right now
[Music]
how much is getting to a jump and
getting over it dependent on the horse
taking you there 98 percent wow her left
eye is a prosthetic as for the right eye
what exactly can you see where I see my
finger when it gets here and then it
disappears at here you see a little bit
of light but again it's blurry
you can't make out quite what it is
right you can see color
I see color very well the minute I see
that white fence with flowers and the
green
I know I need my outside leg
she invited us to her Farm in Wellington
Florida
where she even gave me a chance to ride
with her when did you start riding when
I was three
she grew up at an equestrian center in
Virginia that her mother owned she's
been a champion Rider since the age of
five when she was diagnosed with uveitis
that's a rare inflammatory eye disease
and it made School difficult
was childhood lonely for you
no I had horses it was her mother who
encouraged her to follow her passion and
ride
everything good in my life is because of
my mother my mother knew as much as she
wanted to keep me at home and keep me
safe
she bought me a horse Faulkner never
doubted herself but her fellow
competitors did
they were making fun of my riding that I
should stop I remember looking away from
them because I was crying that was when
I was determined to figure out how to do
it and better than anyone else
enter Milo an inexperienced horse that
Buckner's trainer found in Europe this
horse walked off the trailer
and I looked at it and went yeah and I
looked at this
emaciated
mangy creature Milo needed somebody to
believe in him and bachner did not only
did Milo carry her over jumps
guided her through the countless mental
and emotional obstacles as they traveled
the country together competing and
winning where was Milo ranked in the
country with you in 2004
uh we won the country I get the chills
just listening to you say that well not
only that now I've got the chills
we were so in tune with each other and
we went for three months where we didn't
lose a class the pair's extraordinary
bond is told in her book Milo's eyes
while she was at the top of her game she
says she misunderstood a conversation
between her mother and stepfather that
led her to think the competitions were
costing too much money so bochner
suddenly sold Milo I thought I was
bleeding everyone dry I wasn't
contributing it was a lot of money in
hindsight the decision to sell him was
worst decision of my life because you
had lost more than a champion you lost I
had lost my best friend I had lost my
savior but three and a half years later
and I very quietly said
Milo really and if horses could cry I
could feel his body heaving and of
course I was a mess and I walked down
I said I don't understand and my mom
said I bought Milo back for you I found
him and I bought him back for you and I
looked at her and I said he's mine again
and she said he's always been yours
together again Milo carried bockner to
one more Victory we walked in the ring
and they announced us the entire
Coliseum went silent
and hearing our name together
and so three classes
100 people in each class one every
single one you did
on this horse that was now 16.
almost 17 years old
that was their last hurray
before Milo died at the age of 17. I
knew the moment he was gone because I
felt him go through me it was awful
nothing will replace Milo left here but
listen may have found her next best
partner this is a magnetic
now with less than five percent of her
eyesight remaining she's putting her
trust in a new horse
she calls mango good job
last month we were there as she and
mango won first in their class at the
world Equestrian Center in Ocala Florida
Now 49 years old Lissa bochner is riding
and she's writing with the intention of
helping others to the people who will
watch this and say oh my gosh I'm
inspired by this woman what would you
say I would tell them I knew myself well
enough that to know that I could not
exist without the horses
and that I had to find a way to continue
to ride there are people who don't give
up and don't take no for an answer and I
did not do it myself I had a lot of help
and I had no shame in saying that I
asked for help and I got it
I've seen that story twice now and there
are new lessons in it each time you
watch
all right to our next story cracking
open a good book can take you on an
adventure but sometimes it's not what's
written on the pages but what's left
behind in the book that's what Oakland
Public Libraries found in a book project
is all about Caitlin O'Kane has more
a map of Japan a crochet hook a coupon
for pizza and a recipe for Success these
are the artifacts collected by the
Oakland Public Library all of the
mysterious items were left behind in
books and now they're on display on the
library's website librarian Sharon
McKellar is behind the found in a
library project she was inspired by The
Forgotten mementos she personally found
left in books put out a call to other
Library staff just to see if anyone had
anything they were willing to share and
was just totally inundated with other
people's little collections of things
they had found so as soon as I realized
it wasn't just me who had these things
and enjoyed these things it it was
uh an easy decision I keep it going more
and more artifacts were submitted and
Sharon has added 370 to the library's
online collection but she has a couple
hundred left to add
there are definitely some favorite
anything that's ever created by a kid I
think I love
um there is a drawing of uh that I call
CJ and Dad that's still one of my
favorites that has the dad drawn huge as
kind of a devil with horns and a tail
and a pitchfork and a giant kind of evil
grin and then this tiny little drawing
it's labeled CJ of a little kid with a
brown face
so I just I really I really love the way
kids Express themselves both in drawing
and writing the project is fairly new
but she hopes it inspires people to dive
into books at their local library
because you never know what you're gonna
find one person recognized something
that they had written although they
themselves had not actually been to an
open public library but they live very
nearby in a city nearby
so they're not sure how it landed here
but imagining that it was a note they
had written for somebody else and
another person reached out because one
of the sort of love notes looked very
much like her parents handwriting and
the kind of notes that they used to
leave each other and
her mother
and she had looked at it and agreed that
it very well could have been a note
passed between the mom and the dad who
had lived here in Oakland in the late
80s for a couple of years so that one's
really cool and it's you know it's not a
for sure but it's
um
fun to think that we might know who that
came from whether it's a stellar book
review
a recipe
or a note
books are filled with Mysteries and each
artifact is part of someone's personal
history you just have a sense that a
sense of shared space in a way so even
if you don't know what book this thing
came from even if you aren't the one who
found it you still have a sense that
this is a person who is in the same
Community as me or wasability using the
same resources and during the same
spaces and I think I think part of why
people are especially excited about that
right now is you know we've obviously
been through a bit of a disconnecting
time with covid and
um
so it is a way to sort of feel feel a
connection to people who you don't even
know through these objects
[Music]
just a delightful story there by Caitlin
O'Kane who also happens to be producer
this year show thank you Caitlin coming
up this little boy in the hospital was
gonna miss out on summer camp what
surprise did he get in his hospital room
that made it all a little bit better
and the sweet surprise this boy got at
his lemonade stand that had him overcome
with emotion plus a unique place these
minor league baseball players live stick
around you're watching The Uplift pretty
good arm there
welcome back to the uplift we've got
those heartwarming videos the ones you
just need to see and we're going to
start with a groundhog that has gone
viral a few years ago a gardener in
Delaware noticed someone was eating his
vegetables so he set up a camera and was
able to capture these images the culprit
a Brazen groundhog who sat right in
front of the camera as he ate those
stolen veggies Jeff eventually found a
soft spot in his heart for the groundhog
and named him chunk
now he's not only let's chunk eat the
vegetables I I tell you but he's also
built chunk a little table you see it
there uh and created an Instagram for
chunk and if you're doing social media
yourself you'll be galled to discover
that chunk now has more than half a
million followers how about you
I have less this next little video shows
a little boy named kale there's kale who
was very excited to go to summer camp
just one problem kale has cancer and had
to stay in the hospital for 30 days
straight not fun for anyone so the staff
at little wishes brought summer camp to
kale they built a fort for him right
there in his hospital room so he could
chill as kale likes to do the
organization is dedicated to Bringing
joy to kids in the hospital and it seems
like they did exactly that for young
kale
now let's take a look at this next video
from Lexi Burke who calls herself a
Serial Tipper take a look are you trying
to raise money for anything
with my soccer team but it's a lot of
money so my dad wanted me to pay him
what position are you I'm playing Center
attacking mid it's so good how much is
it three dollars
and I have a change
thank you so much what the heck what the
heck thank you guys so much it's 1100
and this is raised from tons of people
around Nashville and around the country
to help you out because you're working
so hard oh what do you do we're on Tick
Tock
yep let's call him yes
but very safe
yes and we want to make sure you get
home safe with us too
it's amazing Lexi said uh she got
together with Nico after his family uh
or Nico after this video went viral uh
and he's not only excited to go to
soccer camp next year but also to pay
that kind deed forward to others
we're gonna have more of our
heartwarming videos later in the show
but if you want to see even more you can
head to our Facebook page that is
facebook.com
uplift news
coming up meet minor league baseball
players living in an unlikely place with
some unlikely friends also a pilot on a
remarkable Journey all around the world
but there's a catch he's trying to set a
record what record is that find out
after the break
[Music]
the uplift is back and our next video
shows nine-year-old Felix who is excited
to share some news with his grandpa take
a look
what did you do so you know I got two
home runs yeah Two Jacks and then my
grand slam uh I signed the ball for you
okay
oh no I'll put the data out for you and
it says Papa I love you
why did you do that
stop your face
that was so good wow honey
boom
oh it's a very sweet story now to
another story about some other baseball
players before they make it to the major
leagues if they make it some minor
league players live paycheck to paycheck
a lot of them do in fact one team has
found an affordable and unexpected
option though it's a different kind of
living situation here's CBS Chicago's
Charlie DeMar
life in the minor leagues isn't all big
money and glamor especially when it
comes to where you live a lot of people
are in host families and sometimes I've
heard stories they don't have Wi-Fi TV
air conditionings ads I've heard the
situations
it's some scary stories yeah
ask Chase Dawson and Blake Grant Parks
chasing Big League Dreams with the
Schomburg Boomers and they'll tell you
they hit a home run so long you guys
going up yeah okay good after each game
they come home to the most unlikely
place Friendship Village a retirement
community in the Chicago suburbs I've
got three big boxes of these we're
residents like the vibrant Velma
Robinson roam the halls and the greens
here it's not just Bingo and board games
I just are exciting to talk to and
somebody different my first reaction was
really and I was like you know let's do
it velma's awesome I couldn't believe it
was 95. we got a date next Tuesday with
Velma for years velma's made friends
with players younger than her grandkids
he threw out the first pitch I
understand yeah what was that like for
you two or three Boomers have spent the
last nine Seasons here any piece of
advice that is stuck with you keep
chasing your dreams 2-1 to Dawson bingo
great story there as well all right
moving on to our next one Mac Rutherford
is on a solo Journey flying all around
the world alone and if that's not
remarkable enough there is an additional
catch CBS Los Angeles is Michelle Gilly
caught up with Mac during a pit stop in
Orange County
the 17 year old who has flown
practically Around the World in His
attempt to set a record got a kick out
of passing by the Hollywood Sign Monday
morning Matt Rutherford has gone from
northern to Southern California in the
latest leg of the journey and he made a
luncheon fuel stop at Orange County's
John Wayne Airport welcome to Orange
County and John an airport so delighted
to have you with us the teen from
Belgium began his quest at the end of
March in Bulgaria in a few weeks he
hopes to complete his circle around the
globe and become the youngest solo pilot
to ever achieve such a huge Endeavor
sorry if it was in Japan and it's a huge
leg towards the U.S so I had to add
extra fuel tanks just for that one stop
and I did a 10 hour flight over to attu
Island which is completely uninhabited
not a single person
but I landed there safely and everything
was fine Mac Rutherford who comes from a
family of aviators and got his license
at 15 is flying a European Ultra Light
plane so far one of the most harrowing
parts of the trip was flying through a
sandstorm over the Egyptian desert this
is one of the amazing most amazing sites
Ever After the Orange County Pit Stop
Rutherford took off for Cabo San Lucas
if all goes as planned he'll set the
Guinness World Record in a few weeks
when he lands back in Bulgaria how do
you top this
[Music]
I really wanted to do and so I do it
I'll see what then my next challenge
brings me it might be more challenging
might be less challenging but as long as
it's what I want to do I'll be happy
coming up you know those giant pumpkins
at state fairs that when blue ribbons
for being so gigantic there's one how do
they get that big we'll take you to one
Farm where they are growing these giant
gourds and what prompted this reaction
from a six-year-old at the hospital
we'll tell you after the break
[Music]
welcoming home a new baby is exciting
for the whole family but take a look at
how 12 year old Braden and six-year-old
Braxton reacted to their new baby
brother
[Music]
thank you
oh
state fairs they often have contests for
those giant pumpkins but what goes into
growing something that big CBS
Minnesota's Marielle Mose shows us
are you happy girl pumpkin's bigger than
a baby and still growing sit in this
Garden inside the Arboretum this big
pumpkin over here behind me is Audrey
and the smaller one next to me is
Seymour this little shop of horticulture
is a first time project for Annie Claude
and her team at U of M extension one
plant takes about 500 square feet on
average and you just produce one giant
pumpkin from each plant all the green
that you're seeing is actually just two
Vines one for each pumpkin and these
Vines are vital for getting water from
the ground to the pumpkin and all the
water is what makes them get so big so
quickly so they're able to just pump all
of that water into that one pumpkin so
they're growing about 20 pounds a day
right now Claude learned tricks along
the way like bearing The Vines for more
moisture and giving the pumpkins shade
to keep their skin soft so they grow
even bigger but she did run into one
hurdle last week insects started
infecting the vines which can and kill
the pumpkins if it's not dealt with our
team was out here with our intern Noah
cutting little incisions in the vines
doing open Vine surgery and taking those
little worms out and then patching The
Vines back up and they survived it
they're doing great Audrey already
weighs 230 pounds and Seymour is just
over a hundred pounds with Audrey's
growth in the lead she's going to
compete first Audrey is destined for the
State Fair so we're gonna submit her and
she should be about 500 to 600 pounds by
then if everything goes well
gaining 20 pounds a day does sound like
a jolly good time and speaking of a
jolly good times that is our show I hope
it brightened your day and lifted you up
I'm confident it did but you know what I
always say if you want to try again
reruns are free we'll see you next time
on the uplift
[Music]